ne pas relâcher la pression
c'est le leitmotiv des associations
féministes à l'encontre de gérald
darmanin depuis sa nomination au
ministère de l'intérieur
la mobilisation à son encontre ne
faiblit pas pas un déplacement sans
qu'il ne soit chahuter les associations
mettent les bouchées doubles pour faire
démissionner le premier flic de france
dans tout le pays des centaines de
rassemblements ont été organisés pour
dénoncer ce qui est désormais baptisé le
remaniement de la honte
le collectif nous tout a tenté
d'interpeller sur twitter le premier
ministre jean castex
bonjour jean castex votre ministre de
l'intérieur est visé par une enquête
pour viol et a reconnu avoir échangé un
service contre un acte sexuel
en matière d' insulte aux femmes
victimes et de conflits d'intérêts
on pouvait difficilement faire mieux non
gérald darmanin est visé par deux
plaintes
la première en 2009 où il est accusé de
viol par sophie paterson spatz selon la
plaignante darmanin aurait apporté son
appui
en échange de faveurs sexuelles une
relation consentie selon lui cette
affaire est classée sans suite par le
parquet en 2018 la deuxième concerne une
habitante de tourcoing qui affirme avoir
été obligé d'avoir des relations
sexuelles pour un logement hlm en 2015
une enquête préliminaire pour abus de
faiblesse a été classée sans suite le
collectif pouvoir féministe a saisi le
parquet de lille et entend ouvrir les
investigations selon le collectif la
sphère pourrait aller bien plus loin en
dehors de la question du viol et de
l'abus de faiblesse si les faits sont
avérés
si gérald darmanin sollicités ou même
accepté un rapport sexuel avant
d'intervenir en faveur d'une citoyenne
il y à ce que l'on appelle trafic
d'influencé corruption
elisabeth moreno ministre délégué à
l'égalité femmes hommes étaient attendus
sur ce dossier selon elle la sphère
darmanin est un boulet au pied mais il
faut néanmoins laisser le bénéfice du
doute au ministre de l'intérieur
j'ai parlé avec monsieur darmanin j'ai
eu une conversation de femme à homme
avec lui je lui ai dit il faut qu'on se
parle là parce qu'on est dans la même
équipe
ton sujet va être un boulet à porter
pour moi il faut que tu m'expliquer ce
qui s'est passé et ce qu'il m'a dit me
porte à le croire
maintenant je veux mais aussi du côté
des personnes dont j'ai la
responsabilité
les femmes et
jamais elle va menti j'en tirerai toutes
les conséquences gérald darmanin a fait
à nouveau parler de lui après ses propos
à la veille d'un déplacement à nice où
des tirs ont éclaté en plein jour il a
déclaré qu'il fallait stopper
l'ensauvagement d'une certaine partie de
la société
une formule banalisée par la droite
nationaliste française est dénoncé par
l'ensemble de la gauche y compris dans
la majorité notamment par barbara
pompili ministre de la transition
écologique qui a vivement réagi je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on ait un gouvernement au
service de tous les français et qu'on
doit rassembler tous les français c'est
le principal monter les français les uns
contre les autres peut toujours être un
risque si gérald darmanin ne fait pas
l'unanimité au sein de la classe
politique
il peut compter sur le soutien de
nicolas sarkozy son ancien mentor
gérald est un ami j'ai pu compter sur sa
fidélité et sa solidité
je suis quelqu'un de fidèle il peut
compter sur mon amitié
je vous demande de bien comprendre ça
sent la présomption d'innocence
il n'y a pas de démocratie le respect de
la présomption d'innocence
je ne le dis pas parce que gérald est un
ami je le dis pour la démocratie
française et pour l'état de droit
emmanuel macron a lui aussi brandit
l'argument de la présomption d'innocence
si l'exécutif réitère son soutien un
gérald darmanin à matignon l'entourage
de jean castex a affirmé que s'il
enquête révélée le moindre doute
le ministre de l'intérieur devrait
quitter le gouvernement en attendant la
justice a ordonné en juin la reprise des
investigations sur l'accusation de viol
à son encontre